Noi siamo
Michele Innanzitutto grazie per essere
venuto Come è nata la tua passione per
la musica quando hai scoperto che quella
prima parola che tutti quanti i bambini
dicono che non è suono poteva invece
diventare melodia
non lo so
[Musica]
uno dei tuoi pezzi che ti ha reso più
celebre è il diario degli errori ma se
tu dovessi creare un diario delle cose
di cui sei felice so che è difficile una
riusciresti a infilarci Sì sì
No
una domanda
Michele quanto Secondo te all'interno
del tuo percorso artistico all'interno
del percorso in realtà artistico di un
cantante è importante la parola e quanto
la musica
nel microfono 550 e l'apparenza gli
occhiali cosa
rappresentano per te
mi piacevano
arriva mai un momento nel quale pensi
che dopo l'uscita di un pezzo tu non
potrai mai più arrivare a partorire a
creare un qualcosa di
tanto forte o tanto importante
No io lo ringrazio Sì io sono Ti
ringrazio tanto perché sei stato
prezioso è stata una bellissima
chiacchierata
va bene grazie Michele Allora allora
Ciao ragazzi Allora allora Grazie mille
per l'invito veramente io ti devo
partire subito con una con una domanda
Vai una fama senza un vero e proprio
talento Sì Allora ehm ho scoperto che
c'è un sacco di gente come me quando le
persone ehm sono come me cercano i
propri simili il simbolo quindi sono il
simbolo delle persone vediamo quindi
Esatto esatto tu sei un leggero dalla
tua bio o un dottore sì sì sì sì sì sì
ecco dottore Posso parlare
dottore Eh sto laureato Eh lo so ragazzi
è assurdo perché comunque è una giovane
età però sono dottore laurea triennale
ehm lingue per l'impresa come vivi
all'interno parleremo di Tik Tok giusto
l'originalità Allora io ragazzi Vabbè
copio sempre tutte le cose che faccio e
poi comunque alla fine cosa bisogna fare
sul Tik Tok fai i balletti Cantiamo
anche come ti immagini tra 20 anni
Allora mi immagino
Scusate Che spettacolo
Mi immagino Spero non qua e
no guarda mo' ehm scusami se ti chiamo
così e mi immagino all'estero
[Musica]
sapete Iron Man guarda sei stato
prezioso che almeno ci saranno cinque
strati della tua intervista che volevo
farmi tatuare sulla schiena e Michele Tu
hai qualcos'altro da dire No vorrei
soltanto capire cosa si nasconde dietro
questo nome così Audace il Lollo Barolo
e dici Lollo barol cosa si deve
nascondere non me la grafica è questo
Vabbè però Barolo Lollo Barolo Lollo
bello il primo bello bello bello bello
secondo me
Qual è il cognome non lo Barolo così
Grazie ragazzi Grazie mille veramente
per questa intervista Grazie grazie
grazie
Buona ricerca grazie Eccoci qua Ciao
ragazzi Grazie grazie grazie
grazie mille Voi siete il mio Tik Tok Il
mio cantante preferito quindi siamo
tutti preferiti Grazie
quando ha iniziato tutto il percorso sui
social
network
[Musica]
sono una Cicciolina che si è stancata di
avere un nome d'arte voglio tornare alla
frase Senti ma questo punto basso della
tua carriera che insomma gli animali
ricordano come feroci come è stato
vissuto Scusa se te lo chiedo Allora
vorrei essere lì non ci credo però non
mi sembra Mmm io ti ringrazio io credo
che ci sia sempre un momento all'interno
di una giostra dove si sale e si scende
l'importante è che sia divertente sia un
brivido mi sono un po' sentito una testa
di cazzo perché stavo tra due [ __ ]
però ehm ehm in questo l'errore Forse è
stato il team la scelta proprio
artistica Di come di come creare questo
trittico è stata sbagliata mmm mmm
siamo d'accordo Siamo d'accordo tutti
questo grazie mille Guglielmo veramente
diciamo un sacco piacere e mi hai
commosso Sì grazie grazie grazie
[Risate]
ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah
cazzo
tiraglielo giù
[Applauso]
[Musica]
Oggi andiamo da Fabio
perfetto
[Musica]
[Applauso]
Ma dov'è il naso
raga Guardate così
ah ah ah ah ah ah
ah ah
Ah ah ah ah ah
[Applauso]
Ah
mi giuro mamma mia
ah ah ah ah
ah ah ah ah ah ah ah
AH
AH AH AH
AH AH
[Musica]
AH AH sul mio occhio Lollo
io mi sento una persona diversa anche io
migliore amo maturo maturo amo' Io anche
con una bellissima seno
[Applauso]
Fatevi allattare in inglese
ma non vanno i microfoni
[Musica]
le orecchie ragazzi siamo arrivati alla
fine di questo podcast Io sento che
questo percorso mi ha cambiato non so
voi
va diverso leggermente
a me stesso però comunque sai quando
Accogli così tante storie nozioni è
bello
è bello che comunque cioè abbiamo
abbiamo conosciuto persone assurde belle
e ci hanno raccontato la loro storia io
sono veramente contentissimo voglio
veramente sapere
ragazzi chiudiamo sì
Si tirava il naso cercando di
aggiustarsi camera su di me per favore
proprio zero
[Musica]
da noi feroci è tutto
ragazzi e ragazze
Oh grafia No aspetta
un graffio
raga
[Musica]
[Applauso]